I spoke about an old acquaintance with BV first. This is a first-in-human trial of
BI-1808, a tumor necrosis factor 2 or TNFR2 blocker depleter in T-cell lymphomas.
So BI-1808 is an IgG1 monoclonal antibody that targets TNF2 and thereby inhibits the interaction
between the TNF2 receptor and the ligand, which is TNF-alpha. TNFR2 is overexpressed in many T-cell
lymphomas, but also on immune cells in the tumor microenvironment. And when it is overexpressed,
it can promote cancer progression. And early clinical data has shown that there is single
agent activity in several various solid cancers. In addition to direct killing through ADCC of the
malignant T-cells,
we also see a depletion of Tregs and an expansion of effector T-cells and reprogramming of the tumor
microenvironment, including myeloid cells. So here is just a graphic depiction of what
BI-1808 does. So without BI-1808, you have CD4-positive cells that have high expression
of TNFR2, and they can help and promote tumor cell growth.
And they can help and prevent the influx of CD8-positive effector cells. Now, if you add BI-1808,
you deplete these CD4-TNF2 receptor high cells, T-regulatory cells, and you allow activated CD8 T-cells
that are low in TNF receptor 2 to exert immune killing of the tumor cells.
So BI-1808 is a phase one, phase two study. Initially started with all advanced malignancies,
and the dose escalation proportion of that has been completed.
It then moved to the phase 2a with a signal-seeking dose in T-cell lymphoma, and particularly CTCL,
and that's what I will be talking about. And currently, a dose optimization cohort is going on,
so BI-1808 is given every three weeks, IV, and we will be exploring a low dose of 250 milligram
every three weeks as compared to the high dose of 1,000 milligram every three weeks.
For the CTCL cohort, the key eligibility criteria are very standard, 18 years plus, good performance
status. Stage 1b plus is allowed, so including MF and cesarean patients, at least one prior therapy,
and not eligible for standard of care.
Adequate organ function, measurable disease, no CNS involvement, no large cell transformation is allowed.
So this is the early efficacy data of 21 patients were enrolled, but only 13 patients with CTCL were response
available, and two patients with PTCL. For the CTCL patients, here depicted is the M-SWAT, which is the way of how
we assess skin disease.
So the modified severity-weighted assessment tools, and you can see that there is an overall response rate of 46% with one
patient with Cesarean syndrome who achieved a complete response, and all, except for one patient with Cesarean syndrome
having at least stable disease, which is something important in this otherwise difficult-to-treat population.
Of the two PTCL patients, one had APR and the other one had stable disease.
Here is the SWMR plot, just showing that essentially responses can be very durable, and patients even with stable disease,
which can be meaningful in this disease, as I mentioned, can stay on the drug for quite some time.
Looking at the correlatives, it does as it was promised on the graph.
So we have biopsies before and after, and we see a significant increase in CD8 infiltration and accompanying
grandson B elevation at just five weeks after start of therapy.
In terms of side effects, it's a very safe agent.
And while we've seen, of course, 81% of any treatment emergent adverse effect, only one patient really had a grade 3 adverse event or serious
adverse event secondary to BI-1808, and that is most consistent with a disease flare, so a skin reaction followed by pyrexia.
Disease flares are fairly common and are characterized by increased itching, skin peeling, erythema, and happen early on in several of the patients.
And we think it is because of that influx of the CD8 positive T cells.
In summary, the signal-seeking cohort of single-agent BI-1808 for T cell lymphoma shows promising efficacy and is associated with a strong immune activation.
We see an objective response rate of 46% in patients with advanced cutaneous T cell lymphoma, and the study is currently moving on to the dose optimization cohort.
BI-1808 was well tolerated and allowed the exploration of combinations with other agents.
There is another cohort going on.
We see a significant increase in the number of patients with T cell lymphoma with T cell lymphoma with T cell lymphoma with T cell lymphoma of BI-1808 combined with pembrolizumab in CTCL, and also of BI-1808 with various chemotherapeutic agents in solid tumors, particularly in ovarian cancer.
And giving you back a minute for the next few speakers.
Thank you.